وتتجه انظاره الامريكين الان الى
ولايتينفادا واريزونا التي يتنافس
الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون فيهما على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ فيما يتواصل حتى الان فرز
الاصوات في اريزونا تظهر النتائج تقدم
الديمقراطيين بفارق مريح من الاصوات
بحوالي مئه الف صوت بعد فرز اكثر من 76%
من الاصوات اما في نيفادا وهي الولايه
التي ما زالت متارجحه وسط تقدم طفيف
للجمهوريين بفارق نحو
15000 صوت بعد فرزي 84% من الاصوات لماذا
تبقى معلقه حتى اللحظات الاخيره فاذا فاز
الجمهوريون سيكون لهم خمسون مقعدا في مجلس
الشيوخ مقابل 49
وسيكون علينا انتظاره الحسن في جورجيا في
السادس من ديسمبر في جوله الاعاده واذا
تحققت المفاجاه وربح الدي مقعد الشيوخ في
نيفادا فسيعود المجلس لقب داتهم مجددا دون
انتظار نتائج الاعاده في جورجيا
[موسيقى]